Jenna - that's you
hello my name is Justine wait oh I know
oh my gosh look at that great hair oh my
god can i shart be right here yeah you
have one oh my god this is amazing video
the video has started I need a sharpie
what's good one my name is iJustine and
this is my channel today we're gonna be
doing an ask i J
but apparently first we're gonna sharpen
my great hair because I'm aging rapidly
I did your intro okay just don't get my
don't get my my scalp like you gotta
just be gentle there's a couple are you
not looking in the water
oh it's plan a sure is can I do it it's
fine I'm like 900 years old
I'm YouTube has aged me so much older
than you yeah but like oh my god it
looks really nice this is my accent
color but I do want to dye my hair dark
yeah just go get a nice little well
here's the thing those little devilish
pieces still stick out yeah like don't
oh my god should we start at the actual
video now I've cut all over myself
sure do we have an intro song hey hey
you can ask IJ hey hey you can ask I J
why do I still remember that from kiss
you can never forget it this is
incredible because that was like the
first question from David what's your
anti-aging secret you seriously look
20-year whole life well they're talking
to you I look like I'm 7,000 years old
you're still tagged David said love you
and has are he just hit reply but you're
sweet David you're sweet you're sweet
thanks David
when's your makeup line coming out you
probably should do one might as well
look everybody's doing their palettes I
want to do a mascara or a chapstick bro
I know chapstick is a brand so it's a
lip balm I would do chapstick as well I
don't really like to wear makeup me
their moisturizer would be nice
oh maybe I'll make mine with my hair dye
it'll be a sharpie Sharpie tutorial I
got with me cool I did want to do with
like a lip gloss because I love
chapstick and I feel like every time I
buy it it's I don't know I feel like
it's maybe it's making my lips more dry
so that I keep using it I need a really
good one so I should just make my own
Joey wants to know what happened to the
cooking videos and when can we have some
more behind-the-scenes videos what do
they want behind the scenes of I think
we're making our videos I will have to
do that Tyler maybe some like BTS bits
you know like when we're like shooting
we just can set up another another
camera cuz really we need to just have
more content at it so here's some behind
the scenes of Tyler getting behind the
scenes hold on a second here sure I get
behind scenes of behind scenes yeah you
probably should yeah here's our out of
most ninja fives camera I would like to
do more cooking videos I just feel like
when I was doing the cooking videos
there wasn't as much tech at the time so
I would use the cooking videos to kind
of fill in the blanks between the tech
videos and then this last year he was
just so much tech I was overwhelmed the
cooking videos are fun they're just very
time consuming and proud of their time
typically are from setup to editing
because we are a lot of times when we
were doing the making stuff we would
have to already bake that stuff like the
night before so it's like a whole day
process it was leading up to it Evan
wants to know if we remember sharing the
spaghetti I feel like that is something
that you've done it sounds familiar as I
feel like we were going
[Music]
shirring up later - come on John which
is here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh boy I'm not bad at all
tomorrow wants to know what I think
about cryptocurrency I think I lost a
lot of money well we would have gotten a
lot yeah very easy that we didn't cash
out I definitely have cryptocurrency but
I'm not I don't like obsessively follow
it if I did I probably would be doing a
little bit better but at this point I'm
just gonna hold on to it by until
someone's like hey man if there is worth
20 K I'm like yeah cash out my bye
sure we would even hire to share the
spaghetti we could get our long
spaghetti we could open with spaghetti
factory the problems we've got the
spaghetti but they wouldn't give us a
plate so we had to share the spaghetti I
understand we could get two plates
Ronnie wants to know if we're getting
the new animal crossing new horizons
edition switch oh yes it's beautiful
have you seen it yes very nice my gosh I
don't know if I'm gonna get the switch
though well I am because I have a
problem you'd end I could at least say
that's a tax write-off at the end of the
year but you knew that's worried about
the tax write-off it's like your
difference we're still spending the
money and then you yeah no I think you
have enough tax write-offs which I think
I do as well I'm trying to be more
responsible
I have FOMO which is why I end up with
half of the things that I do I don't
need a MacBook Pro it's a magic book
it's another MacBook Pro well I'm
excited for the game I think that I'm
gonna have another set I was telling
Tyler running Animal Crossing we're
gonna get him one have you ever played
it wasn't no oh my gosh oh my goodness
it is an incredible game jared is saying
hey why haven't you checked out the
pixel for
I did Joshua wants to know how was the
Mac Pro verse I Mac Pro maybe not an ama
question but would love to see a video
huh it is it's kind of interesting I
mean I feel like honestly for what I'm
doing probably wouldn't really be able
to tell that much of a difference
because I mean if I am editing a que you
could definitely tell on the iMac but
most of the 4k stuff like it they both
just may run like button hmm
Chris C productions wants to know what
is the best and worst part of working
with your sister no we we have fun and
we do have fun job so we have like the
same brain I feel like sometimes god
people are like but you you did the same
thing as your sister and I'm like
honestly we filmed this completely
separately I haven't even talked to her
like this is just one small brain we
seem to be sharing so a lot of our idea
well we all saw the same interests in
like hobbies so that's like when we
showed up to a shoot and had these same
say right on their sweater ready to go
same sweater yes that's fine um what was
it a question the worst worst probably
is having the same injure my foot I like
it too
I'm so itchy Jenna's edgy I am also
[ __ ] I think because you're itchy is
it your right leg oh that's my doing oh
all right that's different it get you
some cream I think that's like bad type
of it just like this chick just he has a
personal rash that's disgusting
it's my side of my leg I just said my
butt for effect David I think I cut
David asked me two questions but I don't
know it was a good questions I picked it
because I thought Jenna would really
love this the most stupid purchase of
2019 we're trying to think
things stupid you upgraded the Mac Pro I
told you not to well that was the app or
well but I also did this year this year
yes that was working upgrade I mean read
this year I said don't do it
I wanted the four terabytes I'm gonna
take over I found some questions I'm
scared
why xbox of a Playstation I like Xbox
like the controller I like my friends on
Xbox I have a Playstation but it's just
I don't lower the power quarters most of
my friends that Xbox so that's really
that's really it and I'd like the
controller better what did you just say
guys pay attention think similar I
actually think was very similar okay Ari
wants to know what is your favorite
thing to do when you were not making
videos and traveling love to sleep I
also love like elbow you right in the
face but I'm not gonna okay what do you
think of the new Google Maps icon
questionable I like it because I would
always get Google Maps and Apple maps
confused and now I will not do that
anymore
I understand would you ever go back to
vlogging the daily life absolutely not
I would rather have all the way
fingernails ripped off okay oh my next
video ripping off Justine's fingernails
that's cool yeah daily vlogging it is
just not fun
it's not fun it rips your soul out
because you live for the vlog what are
you most looking forward to this year oh
my gosh I want to travel
oh I really want to get a dog this year
well I want to but I'm also scared of
commitment so but what about Maddie I
know you can get brother and sister
brother-sister probably no I got that I
also ask you about it because we both
will have two dogs that's [ __ ]
we're going to ask me how do you ask
Maddie he's gonna go pick out the dog oh
I thought he was gonna rip this other
dog's head off this morning I was like
Matthew what are you doing um make sure
your screen shopping is I'm not okay
chill your job is most fun isolates not
that hard no for example you're lucky
you don't have to go to an office a week
up at 6 a.m. every morning and get paid
like 1/4
you tuber oh I wake up at like 5:00 and
say like this every day
most of these days we're working like
two hours a day you know maybe even
longer
I mean definitely no YouTube is not as
easy as people think
Jonathas claw ah that was just something
I read okay what we need one more good
question
okay one had to pick one camera to use
for a solid month what would the camera
be my phone for everything yeah it's
easy it's great I would probably well I
happy a 7r3
but if I was picketing and then I would
have the a7 or for it she's pick do
anything what those buttons the buttons
are nice it's a really nice I'm holding
out for whatever they release next I'm
still hoping for an a7
s33 alright I think that's the end of
the video
[Music]
hey hey you can ask I J this is a long
video 111 miss phone calls no those are
just the voicemails you have a hundred
and eleven voicemails yeah why doesn't
want to talk to me
you see my miss calls like don't bother
oh my god so basically you guys have to
follow me on Twitter because that's
really the only way that you can get a
hold of me so that's how slide into the
DMZ listen
I know secrets
[Music]